Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul.
One question that I'm frequently asked is what language is most closely related
to English? Well, some people would say Scots,
but that's debated because other people would say that Scott's is a variety of
English leaving that debate aside. If we think of English and Scots together,
then what language is most closely related to them?
The answer is the Phrygian language,
or maybe I should say the Friesian languages in the plural.
Anglo Friesian is a sub-branch of the West Germanic languages.
It consists of the unblock languages, English and Scots.
Or you can think of this as just English, if you want.
And the Friesian languages,
a group of closely related languages that developed from old Friesian old
Friesian and old English were very close to each other,
but that doesn't mean that Friesian and English are mutually intelligible.
Today. English has changed dramatically due to contact with other languages like
Norman, French,
and the various varieties of Friesian have been influenced by Germanic languages
in their respective regions.
The most widely spoken Friesian language by far is West Friesian,
which is spoken by over 450,000 people,
mainly in the free slump province of the Netherlands,
where it's coefficient with Dutch at the provincial level. Then there's North,
Friesian spoken in parts of the state of shoelace V Holstine in
Northern Germany.
It's spoken by fewer than 10,000 people and is considered endangered.
Then there's softer land Friesian,
which is only spoken by a couple of thousand people in one municipality software
lumped in the lower Saxony state in Germany,
softer lumped Friesian is seriously endangered.
As most of its speakers are older.
All three Friesian languages consist of a number of dialects,
even softer lumped freezer with three villages, having their own dialects.
Friesian used to be spoken over a much wider area of the North sea coast.
Old Friesian was spoken and written throughout the 15th century,
but lost its status as a written language.
When rulers of free slump made Dutch the dominant language first under Duke
Albert, the third of Saxony, then under Habsburg rule,
then under an independent Netherlands in which Holland was dominant a quick side
note. What's the difference between Holland and Netherlands?
I thought they were the same. Nope,
just like England is only one part of the United Kingdom.
Holland is only one part of the Netherlands, actually two parts,
the provinces of North Holland and South Holland.
The other provinces including free Friesland are part of the Netherlands,
but not part of Holland.
So Holland became the most influential part of the Netherlands and Dutch remains
the dominant language.
Friesian became mainly a spoken language for a long time.
And this period coincides with the middle Friesian period over a century later
in the 17th century,
Friesian poet geese belt Yupiks wrote poems and Friesian to revive it as a
literary language. Then Johann,
this hilar abyss began trying to standardize written frictions, orthography,
and pronunciation. While the APIX wrote in a more traditional literary style,
he loved this,
tried to make the standard language more similar to how people actually spoke
another Friesian Yahoo, Hulbert, smart, translated, many plays and books,
including the Bible into modern West Friesian.
And this is what really started the movement to preserve modern West Friesian.
And that movement picked up in the early 20th century and continues till this
day. So what is modern Friesian like, well,
that depends on which of the three main varieties we're talking about because
they are distinct languages in this video. We'll focus on West.
Friesian the most widely spoken Friesian language. First,
some basic phrases in West region. Hello. Good morning.
Gleam on please. Uh, she blazed I'd like some coffee please.
[inaudible] thank you. Tongal thank you very much. Diesel Doug.
Note that unlike English Frisian doesn't have dental fricative sounds like pho
as an English. Thank you. Or the, as an English that,
excuse me, where's the restroom.
I understand. I don't understand.
I love free salons.
It called from fresh lawn. Holy sh Blix gender.
Now let's examine some sentences in Friesian the sentence means those are her
books.
As.
You can see the syntax here is the same in both languages.
And most of the words are all cognitive. This one may look different,
but it resembles the word bean in English. Doesn't it?
This is a form of the verb, meaning to beat,
which is cognate with the English word, but in West Africa,
the infinitive is which makes more sense. If you look at the past tense forms,
book-in is the plural form.
Frisian has two ways of forming the plural N or E N four nouns that have a
stressed final syllable and S for nouns that end in unstressed
syllables.
And also after diminutive vendings this sentence has a possessive adjective,
but how was possession shown? If we specify who the possessor is with a name,
for example, those are FENOs.
Books.
Possession can be expressed with agenda to vending on the note,
similar to English,
apostrophe S old Frisian had a system of numerous grammatical cases
for nouns, but just like in English,
those case forms have been lost except for the genitive.
But the genitive case form has become much less common to,
and now it's much more common to use the word fun to express possession
word for word it's.
Those are the books of FENa notice that the definite article the comes
before the now and then fun comes after it.
Another way that might be even more common is this
[inaudible] Word. Those are her books.
The possessive adjective is used in place of the genitive ending.
It's interesting that these pair of frantic ways of expressing the genitive have
become more common than the genitive ending.
It seems to show the continued erosion of the Friesian case system.
Going back to this sentence for a second.
Note, the.
Definite article D there is one more definite article.
It Friesian has two grammatical genders, Coleman gender,
and the neuter gender is used with singular common gender nouns.
And with all plural mounts,
it is used with singular neuter nouns book is neuter,
but it's in the plural form.
So it's definite article is the let's try making that sentence singular.
That is feminists book.
Double-digit notice that.
The definite article is it because book is singular neuter. Also,
as we saw before with the plural sentence,
possession can be expressed in those other ways, too, though, this fan,
this is possible, but not common anymore.
Delta spend the hot book is the most.
Common.
You may have noticed that the demonstrative pronoun.like that in English
is used for both singular and plural. In other words,
for both that and those in West Friesian,
there's a distinction between demonstrative pronouns and demonstrative
adjectives. The demonstrative pronouns are DIT, meaning this or these Mr.
For both genders and dot meaning that,
or those also used for both genders,
demonstrative pronouns are used as equivalents or substitutes of the noun.
Demonstrative adjectives are used to modify nouns and come directly before them
for common gender singular and for all plural nouns DISA,
meaning this or these and D meaning that or those.
And for neuter singular nouns, DIT,
meaning this and dot meaning that here's a pair of sentences to
show you the distinction between demonstrative pronouns and demonstrative
adjectives.
Don't be in a horrible can. DBU can benefit from the heart.
Another sentence. She has read 15 books this year.
She had it a year, 15 book and Lazarus.
Word for word it's.
She has this year 15 books read this sentence begins with the
personal pronoun sheet, which is a cognitive English sheet.
Basically all the personal pronouns in West Friesian are cognitive equivalents
of the ones in English. Next,
we see the third person singular present tense conjugation of the verb.
The present tense forms correspond quite closely with the English present tense
forms. But look at the past tense forms in English.
The past tense conjugations collapsed into a single past tense form based on the
first and third person singular forms,
but Friesian still maintains distinct past tense conjugations.
Next we see it DIT year. Meaning this year,
year is a neuter singular note.
So the demonstrative adjective is DIT rather than DISA. Next.
We see the number 15, obviously a cognate with English 15.
Let's hear a few more numbers.
An [inaudible] fee,
our fee if to return.
All of these numbers are cognate with English numbers,
but there's a difference in numbers like 34, three,
literally four and 30 lesson is the past participle form
of the verb.
Lazur meaning to read Lazur has cognates in numerous Germanic
languages,
including Dutch Layson and German lays in another sentence.
This one means we usually stay at home in the evening
Word for word it's. We stay normally in the evening at home.
The verb [inaudible] is a cognate of the English word, but live,
which means stay or remain. What is obsolete in the standard language?
Not a model is like normal or normally of course,
of course you could say normally in English as well,
making these two sentences more similar units is the genitive form of
human, which means evening.
The genitive form of nouns is sometimes used as a temporal advert marker to form
adverbs of time. Finally,
the word Touche was originally a contraction of two words, TA plus,
which this is the equivalent of the Dutch word toasts one final sentence.
Almost everyone went home early because of the storm.
[Inaudible] was fun way for this to Adam.
It's almost everyone went early to home because of the storm.
This word El Canadian can be broken down into two parts,
meaning precisely every plus one,
this word Ghia is the third person singular past tense,
conjugation of GaN, the verb,
meaning to go in old English and an old Frisian. It was gone,
but teed one part of this word tead means time.
The first part is related to a preposition B meaning by or apt,
but this is now an inseparable word fond with her.
This word means because of,
but can be broken down into the parts meaning of plus way though,
because of the spelling of Wayfair.
I think this might be a lone word from Dutch Von wafer. Finally,
still autumn is a singular common gender now. So what's definite article is the,
rather than it.
Hopefully you can see that West Friesian is a language that shares much in
common with English,
but that also shares a lot in common with other Germanic languages.
Sometimes seemingly more so than with English,
but don't make the mistake of thinking that West Friesian is a dialect of Dutch
or that the other varieties of Friesian are dialects of German.
They are distinct languages that are worthy of recognition and preservation.
The question of the day for native speakers of any of the Friesian languages,
how much do you use Friesian in your day-to-day life and how much do you use a
different specifically Dutch or German?
And for other people does West Friesian seemed similar to English to you.
What stood out to you as being similar, a special,
thanks goes out to my Patrion supporters,
especially these wonderful people right here on the screen.
They are my top tier Patrion supporters. So many extra special,
thanks to them as always.
If you're interested in learning Friesian one place you can start is learn
friesian.com.
The guy who runs the site actually provided the Friesian samples for this video.
It's a free language course. Something like duo lingo for Friesian.
So give it a try and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.